Andrés gracias por invitarme mira lo más
impresionante es la cantidad de
migrantes que están cruzando por allí
diariamente junto a Johnny talcahuates
estuvimos haciendo este reportaje y
pudimos ver cómo son más de 3000
personas que están diariamente
arriesgando sus vidas cruzando esta
selva inhóspita con el sueño de llegar a
los Estados Unidos
cuál diría que es el mayor peligro para
esos migrantes la naturaleza hostil o
las mafias que controlan la zona
la naturaleza es bastante hostil en la
región también siento que hay una
situación compleja de desinformación en
estas personas muchos no no conocen bien
el lugar Hacia dónde van No están
entrenados no tienen la preparación
física y el equipamiento necesario para
sobrevivir en la selva
muchos sienten que es algo fácil de
hacer que si otros lo lograron ellos
pueden pueden hacerlo y eso los ponen en
unas condiciones complejas porque es una
selva bien dura bien difícil muy
exigente y
el tema de individuos también pueden
estar en control de la región aumenta el
nivel de peligro usted mencionaba hay
falta de información y como lo veíamos
en el informe anterior muchos migrantes
terminan sin ninguna solución al llegar
a la frontera entre México y Estados
Unidos esto lo saben las personas que
están en el Daniel
algunas personas lo saben algunas
personas también que están cruzando en
este momento entre
Panamá y México lo saben y están ahí
preguntándose qué hacer sé que en
necoclí hay un momento de crisis que se
está viviendo algunas personas se han
devuelto incluso desde capurganá que es
la puerta de entrada de la selva hacia
necoclí a todo esto es complejo Es
realmente la situación compleja Porque
eso los tomó por sorpresa es una una
norma que empieza a regir desde el
momento en el que Se expide y muchas
personas estaban sin aviso debe haber
personas que están en este momento
atravesando la selva que no tienen
acceso a internet o a un teléfono porque
allí no hay señal de nada durante varios
días y cuando salgan se van a enterar de
que de que esto sucedió
ahora en sus fotos Federico se ven
muchos niños que nos dice esto de los
migrantes que arriesgan sus vidas en
esta selva
muchos de los migrantes vendieron sus
propiedades sus cosas dejaron todo atrás
porque porque creo que la mayoría tenían
la idea de irse a los Estados Unidos y
no regresar nunca
y ahora no tienen otra alternativa más
que regresar pero no tiene nada donde
Regresar invirtieron todo lo que tenían
en hacer esta travesía
Y eso bueno los ponen una situación
complicada legal y emocionalmente
también